- You know when you get that first sip in?
Almost clogs your heart, oh yeah.
- Welcome to Worth It, f**k me.
- Can one of you clap?
- Worth It UK.
The show where we test
three different things
at three drastically
different price points,
to determine which is the most worth it.
- I'm Rich.
- I'm Ada.
- Tea connoisseur.
- Sounds the best.
- This week, the drink of the UK,
more important than water.
- Pretty much guaranteed.
- Tea.
- Have about 20 cups a day I have to say.
- Wait is that genuine, like 20?
- A day without tea means
I haven't left my bed.
It's a bleak day.
- Yeah.
- Joe!
- Who are you?
- Oh, I'm Joe.
- Honestly, what about that seat there?
First stop, Cabman's
Shelter, basically fantastic
spots to get tea for cab drivers.
- You don't have to be a cab driver.
- They came in around
1800s, a lot of the time
taxi drivers would take a
break, but go into pubs.
These things were built
as a sort of rest stop,
that didn't serve alcohol.
- So they were drunk driving horses?
- Yeah.
(upbeat jazz music)
- My name is Tracy Edwards.
Cabman's Shelter started back in 1875,
so that's why we have the bar,
for you to tie up the horses.
Anybody can order from the hatch,
but only taxi drivers
can come and sit inside.
My press is you just
gotta have boiling water,
fresh tea bag, and just make
individual tea for everybody.
I'm very proud of myself,
we should have a cup of tea.
- Can I have the Arsenal mug please?
- That actually belongs to Keith.
- These are specific mugs
owned by people?
- Yeah, these are,
the Werst Ham one is my delivery man.
So there's some builder at
the window called spider.
- That's whose everywhere.
- And you put these crystal
palace ones, so good old spider.
- Good old spider.
- Yeah.
- What would happen if
Keith saw me drinking out
of his Arsenal mug?
- Don't mess with Keith.
So today you two are just going to have a
standard cup of tea, for 70 pence from me.
- Tracy was incredibly
kind and offered us a seat
in the shelter,
unfortunately our sound man
broke the rules.
He's been ejected, disgraced
himself a little bit.
But you know what, I
kinda like this setting.
- No, this is a nice Instagram wall.
- All I need is my horse tied up here.
- Yeah.
- Cheers.
- Beautiful cup of standard
English breakfast tea,
doesn't get better than that.
- Tracy knows what she's
doing, she's done like
the perfect mix hasn't she?
- For the first cup of the
day, this is everything I need.
- There's not really a
science to it, it's more like
second nature isn't it--
- Yeah, its a feeling for her.
- If you think about
the amount of tea that
this shelter has churned out.
- I think may get my vote.
- And the price--
- 70p.
- Anything that has a p after it is a
bargain these days right?
- Yeah.
- Even a bottle of water
is at least a pound.
- I got a joke.
Every time I have a
tea, it ends with a pee.
(laughing)
- Just go over there mate.
Do you have a fact?
- What sort of fact?
Oh, a tea fact--
- A tea fact.
- Tea bags were invented in 1908.
- No.
- Yeah, Thomas Sullivan, in America.
- That's true?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Joe where did you get
these facts, Wikipedia?
- No, see that...
We are after Timberyard in Soho,
it prides itself on the
reverse osmosis that
it uses with its water,
I don't know what that means,
but it sounds very impressive really.
- It's interesting that you said water,
tea is the second most
popular drink in the
world, after water.
But I never drink it after water.
(laughing)
- Joe, get out the cab.
(upbeat pop music)
- We're at Timberyard,
in the heart of Soho.
My name's Darren.
What we specially add to
tea and coffe, is we wanted
to make sure it was really high quality,
we've sold some amazing
teas, the basis of our blend
is a Kenyan, and then we
have a Rwandan, it's more
aromatic and it kinda
lifts the Kenyan a little,
so it balances it off, the
final singular tea in there
is a Hunan, from China, which
has a natural smokiness,
with a little bit of hot crust bun like.
- So blend is like a tea cocktail.
- We use a reverse osmosis system
to filter our water,
creates the right balance
of minerals for a really beautiful tea.
Service itself is a bit of theater,
we measure five grams of tea leaves,
that's brewed with water at 93 degrees,
its quite specific and then left to sit
with an additional timer and
we set it for five minutes.
It seems a long time to a lot of people,
but this is specialty
tea, it takes a little
bit longer to brew really well.
It's a different process,
it takes you five
minutes for a really lovely intense cup.
A pot of our English breakfast
tea is three pounds 90.
- Alright, so we have
four and a half minutes.
- Joe, have you got a joke for us?
- There are only two main types of tea,
uppercase and lowercase.
(laughing)
- That is so bad that it is funny.
- Oh, do you want to do the honors?
So this is optimal time to pour the tea.
Oh look at the color.
- It's like almost as red as the cup.
- Cheers.
- You know, I've discovered,
you're a slurper.
- No, don't say that.
What are you talking about?
- Excuses, excuses.
- I'm not.
Everyone be quiet.
- Ooh.
(laughing)
- Yeah, that, that was accidental.
I thought the tea was closer to my mouth
and it wasn't, let me
do that one more time.
It's hot if you don't slurp.
It's really hot.
(laughing)
Oh, I'm breaking out a sweat.
- I get what he was
saying about the smell,
this would really pair
well with hot crust buns.
- With a hot crust bun.
- Yeah.
- It is lovely actually.
- It an enhanced standard cup of tea,
like you could have this in your house.
- But you'd probably want
to have it with a good show.
- Something that's on once a week.
- Do you want the top up?
A very good size.
- Like there's some places where the cups
are almost too big, so
by the time you finish
your tea its cold.
- Sometimes when I'm having a
cup of tea, I like to balance
it because I'm too lazy to reach for it
and put it on the coffee table.
- We're going to have
an accident in a minute.
- I really liked it, I
just feel very content.
- You want to get your
tea, move off, lets go,
but here you want a tea,
maybe a brownie, maybe
a biscuit, a little chit chatty.
- Royal China Club in Marylebone.
- Okay, no problem.
- Next stop, pretty fancy place.
Prides itself on its extensive
Chinese tea collection.
- Tea fact.
You know why they call it Macho tea?
Cause its hard.
(laughing)
- Was that a joke?
- Yes.
- Your facts suck Joe.
I don't think they call
it Macho, isn't it Macha?
- It's Matcha.
(orchestral music)
- I am Jason Chen.
PR manager of the Royal China Group UK.
We don't add milk to the tea, or sugar.
We make it plain,
its good for your health, cleansing.
There are different kinds of tea
there's the air, the humidity,
the weather, the soil.
The tea we're tasting today,
are one of the more expensive,
Da Hong Pao, 50 years old,
the flavor is like the wine,
vintage tea.
We can only use special pots,
only brew for time posed,
otherwise you ruin the clay,
but they're served into
a different jar, means the
tea leaf, doesn't get too much
flavor out of it, the
first fill, pour it out,
clean the extra tea leaves, then on the
second filling, we start drinking.
This is such a different
type of tea, I cannot
find these kind of words in England.
- Is there anything in
Chinese you would say?
- Hei-ung Shun.
Is the feeling, rather then
just a taste on the tongue.
- So it's an experience.
- Yeah.
Sell it to the customer
for 80 pounds a pot.
- The most expensive tea we will probably
ever taste in our life.
- Are you gonna shot it?
- Absolutely not.
Its all shrouded and mystery.
I don't really know what
these tea leaves have
seen exactly where they've come from.
I love how delicate it is.
- I would buy an incense candle of this
- I was just thinking that thing,
that it's exactly like incense.
You'd want this smell while
you're having a massage.
We do this, are we doing thing?
- Yeah.
- Cheers.
(suspenseful music)
- That is a lot lighter then I expected.
I think its quite earthy.
- It tastes like this kind of golden, like
I can't find the right words
to describe the taste of it.
The words tea, just tastes like tea.
- Yeah.
You know when you have wood
smoked fish and the smell
you get from that is basically the taste
that you get in this.
- Wood.
- We've said that, another one.
- Ogre.
(laughing)
- What is interesting
is with the other teas
you take like a pretty big gulp of it,
this you take a tiny sip.
- Yeah that's true, I get the feeling,
the smoothness.
- The throat feeling
he's talking about.
- It's an experience, its
not about the taste buds,
its about the feeling you get right here.
- Andrew, you're the
pro, tell us what flavors
we are tasting in this.
- Slurper.
- Slurp in action.
- Nothing wrong with it.
(suspenseful music)
- It really dries out your mouth.
- It does.
(laughing)
Yeah.
Whose you're worth it winner?
- Really liked the Royal China Club,
I thought it was rawer, but Timperyard
is my winner because its so cozy,
and he was a tea connoisseur.
- Yeah, you're stuffed in
thee, but my favorite is the
Cabman's shelter.
- Cause of Tracy?
- Oh, yeah I love Tracy,
Tracy was amazing.
Just no nonsense you know.
Joe, one word to sum this
place up, Cabman's Shelter?
- Timberyard?
- Royal China Club?
- Who told you you were tasty?
(laughing)
- Can I be something other than posh?